raúl bastantes reacciones acá en eeuu
después de este polémico discurso del
presidente rompió anoche un discurso que
dio después de 48 horas de no hablar la
primera reacción incluso antes de que
acabara su discurso ya el medio es ms en
bici pues suspendió completamente la
transmisión del discurso y dijo que lo
que estaba diciendo el presidente eran
completamente falso que no estaba
respaldado que no tenía hechos para
respaldar que había fraude y que habían
votos ilegales algo parecido hizo la
cadena ibis y tienen civiles que aunque
estuvieron igual transmitiendo el
discurso del presidente ponían en la
parte de abajo un letrero claro que
decía los votos se seguirán contando
entre las otras reacciones está también
la del candidato su opositor el
demócrata joe bailén que dijo en su
cuenta de twitter que están haciendo
todos los esfuerzos legales es de hecho
dijo que es el esfuerzo histórico más
grande en el partido demócrata para
proteger la democracia proteger el voto
de los americanos porque insiste que
cada voto tiene
que ser compadre ahora cristóbal cómo va
el conteo de votos en georgia donde
bardem tiene hasta el momento una leve
ventaja sobre el presidente de una
trampa
si raúl ya con el 99% de los votos
contados en georgia bailén le lleva una
leve ventaja de un 0,1 por ciento en el
voto es una tendencia que se revirtió
teniendo en cuenta que pues desde que
empezaron los conteos el 3 de noviembre
donald trump estaba adelante de bailén
en georgia lo importante de georgia raúl
es que ofrece 16 votos electorales los
mismos votos electorales de nevada y
arizona juntos es decir que con el 99
por ciento de la votación ya contada si
bailén gana georgia queda con estos 16
votos electorales que le darían
automáticamente la presidencia porque lo
llevarían a esta cifra de los 200 votos
electorales una tendencia además que
revierte precisamente por los votos por
correo que incluso el mismo presidente
de trump decía ayer pues favorecen al
demócrata joe biden una tendencia
también que vemos en otros estados como
pensilvania y que vemos también en
arizona y en nevada como el voto por
correo está
pues ayudando los intereses de job armen
de llegar a la presidencia